[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يسعد صباحكم يا جماعه
بدايه حابب هيك ابدا خطابي بسؤال وقد يكون
هذا السؤال غريب للبعض
لو قررنا نرسم دائره بدون ما نستعمل فرجار
او اي ادوات هندسه مين فينا الان معلش
كيف نرسم دائره بدون فرجار
حلو
حلو جدا طيب هذا السؤال كان سؤال في
اختبار التمس الدولي للرياضيات والعلوم
وكنت انا مراقب على هذا الاختبار
وبدات الطلاب يطلعوا على بعض
صاروا كانهم مستغربين هذا السؤال كيف بدنا
نرسم دائره بدون فرجار فانا استغربت
وسالت الطلاب بالفعل انتم مش عارفين ما
عندكم اي حل قالوا نعم ومحتارين مستغربين
كيف بدنا نرسم دائره بدون فرجار
فانا بدات السائل هل الموضوع له علاقه
بقدرات دماغنا ام ان الموضوع له علاقه
باستعمال هذا الدماغ
في عام 1955
توفي عملاق الفيزياء في العالم اينشتاين
ودخل اينشتاين الى المشفى
هناك اينشتاين
وبدا يتعامل مع هذا الموضوع على اعتبار ان
هذا الدماغ الثمين جدا
وهذا الدماغ يجب ان يدرس اجرا عليه دراسه
ثنتين ثلاث واربعه وصور وغيرها
وتفاجا انه دماغ اينشتاين يختلف عن دماغنا
احنا البشر العاديين
بين الايمن والايسر هناك الياف اكثر من
احنا العاديين
والخليه العصبيه في بعض المواقع في الدماغ
هي اكثر ذكاء
واكثر تشعيبا
العلماء دخلوا في جدال وحوار ليش اينشتاين
دماغه هيك وهذا الجبال والحوار اجري عليه
دراسات كثيره وفي النهايه
اتضح السبب
وجانا الدكتور طوني بوزان في بريطانيا مع
مركز ابحاثه وقلنا انه استعمال الدماغ
يؤثر على طبيعه الدماغ الماديه العضويه
يشكل طبيعه الخليه العصبيه تكون اكثر ذكاء
وتشعيبا او اقل
لهذا بدات الان افكر
اذا كان كل ما اخذنا نفس القدرات اللي
اخذها اينشتاين
ازمتنا وين
ازمتنا هي في استعمال هذا الدماغ
والسبب اللي دخلنا فيه اننا تبنينا منظومه
التفكير البنكي نظام التعليم البنكي اللي
انتشر في العالم في معظم العالم الا مناطق
شرق اسيا اليوم
التعليم البنكي كما قال منظر
البرازيل
قال التعليم البنكي هو ان نقدم للناس
قوالب معرفيه محدده يحفظها
ويسترجعها بالامتحان وتصبح النتيجه
متدني جدا
وفي هذا النظام
بسبب يعني طولنا في وقعدنا فتره طويله
العلماء قالوا تبرمجنا على هذا النظام
واصبح الان الخروج منه متعب وصار يشكل لنا
منطقه راحه نرتاح فيها
لذلك بدات انا وفريد في مدرستي والمحيطين
به بلشنا نفكر كيف بدنا نغادر منطقه
الراحه وكيف بدنا نتحمل المسؤولين وبصراحه
صعب جدا قضيه مغادره مناطق الراحه
اينشتاين يوم غادر منطقه الراحه قالوا عنه
ملحد وحاولوا قتله واين شيطان قدم ابحاثه
لجامعه في سويسرا ورد عليكم
اول خطوه خارج منطقه الراحه تحتاج الى
قرار
اشتغلنا بهذا القرار بقوه
جبنا لكل طلابنا
ومعلوماتنا دفتر جميل سمينات صديق النجاح
وهذا صديقنا في الطريق الان للتغيير الى
التفكير الريادي الابداعي
وبدانا
بكتابه 20 سبب ليش انا بدي اطلع من هاي
المنطقه
وبعدها 30 40 50 لو وصلنا ل 100 سبب ليش
بدي اغادر منطقه الراحه
بعد ما استقرت هذه الاسباب عنا وقوي الهدف
في جوانا انطلقنا الان
الخطوه الثانيه اشتغلنا على موضوع فكر كما
يفكر الاطفال
دراسه تشير الى ان الطفل قبل ما يدخل اي
مرحله تعليميه
يستعمل الذكاء الابداعي بنسبه 95 الى 98%
بجرب كل شيء بحلم بركب بيعمل اي شيء من
باب التجربه وبعدها
اذا دخل الى النظام التعليمي بلش ينزل لان
بلشت الان التعليم البنكي والقوالب
المعروفه تيجي للطالب بلش مستواي في
التفكير الابداعي
بصير يستعمل من 50 ل 70 واذا وصل مرحله
الثانويه والجامعات ينزل من 30 الى 50
واذا اصبح بالغ مثلنا
بوصل اقل من 20 مع شديد الاسف
فلذلك لماذا لا نفكر مثل الاطفال نجرب كل
شيء نفتح فضاءات التفكير نعدد مصادر
التفكير عندنا حتى نقط خطوه جديده اسالكم
سؤال مين فيكم الان بيعرف كم خطوه من بيته
للمدرسه مين فيكم بيعرف كم درجه في
العماره مين فيكم الان بيعرف كم مره بنطوا
اللقمه اذا حطها بثمه مين فيكم بيعرف
اشياء وكان مره بالسائق في اليوم وهذه
الجزء من الوعي الذاتي لنا لننتبه لحياتنا
الخطوه اللي بعدها قدر دماغك دماغنا عملاق
يا جماعه عملاق كبير جدا
افضل منهاج في العالم اليوم في اي جامعه
هو تافه مقارنه مع قدرات الدماء
فكره الذاكره الجباره بدا بعض الناس يحفظ
معجم اللغه الانجليزيه في عشر ايام فقط
انا بدات في مدرستي وانطلقت كيف بدي ازرع
الثقه بعقول اولادي
ادخلها لجوه رؤسهم وبدات بما يسمى بالخطاب
التحفيزي
حضرتم الاستبراون وهو يخطب ويحفظ شركات
عملاقه
سمعناهم كثير بعدين كتبنا خطاب تحفيزي لنا
نقرا كل يوم في نهايه الاذاعه المدرسيه
وكل المدرسه تردد انا عملاق انا جبار
استطيع ان افعل ما اريد حتى نصل في
النهايه الى زرع الثقه في داخل اطفالنا
بان عقلك يستطيع
المساله اللي بعدها والمهمه جدا احنا
جمعنا استعمل نصف الدماغ ومرات ربعه
سبيري في الاربعينات الى 81 وهو يدرس نصفي
الدماغ كل 81 اخذ جائزه نوبل على فلسفه
نصفي الدماغ
سبري جابلنا نظريه ان الدماغ ينقسم الى
قسمين ايمن وايسر
وان الايمن يعمل على كل الجماليات في
حياتنا ويقرا لغه الجسد وان الايمن يركز
على اكثر من شيء في ان واحد
وان الدماغ الايمن قادر على الابداع في
مجال اللغه اللي هي اللغه الجميله مثل
القصائد وغيرها وقادر وقادر اما الجانب
الايسر فهو للتحليل والتركيب وترتيب
الاشياء والابداع في الرياضيات والعلوم
وغيرها من القضايا الان كيف نعمل بنصفيه
الدماغ
استراتيجيه الاولى
يجب علينا ان نفكر الان وناخذ اولادنا
معنا
ان نفكر بموضوع الخيال كم يستعمل الخيال
في الجامعاتنا اليوم وفي مدارسنا عالميا
انا بقول الان النسبه قليل جدا الدول اللي
استعملت الخيال مثل المانيا الان مثل
سنغافوره وبعد الدول التعليم خطا خطوات
متقدمه جدا بسبب هذا الخيال اينشتاين ركب
على شعاع الشمس وماشا الى ما لا نهايه رجع
مكان رجع بنفس المكان اللي كان فيه
ديزني قال رايت ابتسامه الاطفال قبل ان
انتج اي فيلم للاطفال
اديسون قلنا رايت المدن المضاءه قبل ان
تضع هذه المدن او قبل ان اكتشف المصباح
خيال قضيه مهمه جدا استعملنا الخيال بقوه
حريه مطلقه ما حدا بقدر يسيطر عليه انت حر
كما قال فرانكلين في الحريه المطلقه هذا
الكتاب الجميل تستطيع ان تفعل ما تشاء
بخير
ماذا لو سؤال يجب ان يبقى في مدارس
المساله اللي بعد الخيال استراتيجيات
الحديثه
جربنا يا اخواننا واخواتنا موضوع
بعض الاستراتيجيات زي القبعات الست
لديبونو اصبح ولادنا في السابع والثامن
بيقولوا لا معلمه العربي النص كان ناقصه
جانب عاطفي
ناقصه شيء ايجابي او سلبي او غيرها وجربنا
كثير واسكبر روحت بنت من المدرسه
شو بنقدر
عشر اسئله سالتها اللي بيسالها
الموضوع اللي بعده
بدنا نشتغل بقوه على القراءه والقراءه
الفنيه الجميله الرمزيه التي تحاكي الدماغ
وتستفز الدماغ كمان بدنا نشتغل على
الالعاب الالعاب التعليميه الذكي جدا
بدل ما يظلوا اولادنا يلعبوا اي العاب وقد
تؤثر على الدماغ خلينا نروح على العاب
الذكاء اليوم النت مليان العاب ذكاء
المساله اللي بعدها بدنا نحاول ان نسجل في
دفتر نسميه بنك المشكلات عوده اولادكم وين
ما يمشوا في القاعه في البيت في المدرسه
ان يكون في عنده بنك مشكلات تجمع المشكلات
وكما قال احد العباقره ان المشكله هي
بدايه التفكير الابداعي ان تكتشف المشكله
وتحدد تفاصيلها بدايه التفكير الابداعي
هذا الموضوع مهم جدا في حياتنا كيف نخرج
من هذه الدائره الى الدائره اخرى انا
باقول لكم النتائج مع ان انا لا املك كل
المصادر لااا واوفر لطلاب كل هذا الكلام
لكن النتائج جميله جدا جدا بل رائعه في
النهايه احنا بدنا نوصل لا ثالث قضايا كيف
نفكر بطريقه ذكيه وكيف نكتب افكارنا
وكيف نقدم افكارنا للناس هذا هدفنا
النهائي شكرا جزيلا لحضوركم يعطيكم الف
عافيه